i've already made videos on the arc
arc sine
and the arc tangent so to kind of
complete the trifecta i might as well
make a video on the arc cosine and just
like the other inverse trigonometric
functions the arc cosine is kind of the
same thought process if i were to tell
you that the arc
i'm doing cosine if i were to tell you
that the arc cosine
of x is equal to theta this is an
equivalent statement to saying that the
inverse
cosine of x is equal to theta these are
just two different ways of writing the
exact same thing and as soon as i see
either an arc anything or an inverse
trig function in general my brain
immediately rearranges this my brain
originally immediately says this is
saying that if i take the cosine
of some angle theta that i'm going to
get x
or if i get or the same statement up
here either of these should boil down to
this if i say that the cos you know what
is the inverse cosine of x my brain says
what angle can i take the cosine of to
get x so with that said let's try it out
on an example
let's say that i have
the arc
i'm told no i've put two c's there i'm
told to evaluate the arc cosine
of minus one-half
my brain i you know let's say that this
is going to be equal to it's going to be
equal to some angle
and this is equivalent to saying that
the cosine
of my mystery angle is equal to minus
one-half and as soon as you put it in
this way at least for my brain it
becomes a lot easier to process so let's
draw our unit circle
and see if we can make some headway here
so that's my
let me see i could draw a little
straighter
actually maybe i could actually draw
put rulers here and if i put a ruler
here maybe i can draw a straight line
let me see no that's too hard
okay so that is my
y-axis that is my
x-axis
not the neatest most neatly drawn axes
ever but it'll do
and let me draw my unit circle looks
more like a unit ellipse but you get the
idea and the cosine of an angle is
defined on the unit circle definition is
the x value on the unit circle so if we
have some
some angle the x value is going to be
equal to minus one half so we go to
minus one half right here
and so the angle that we have to solve
for our theta is the angle that when we
intersect the unit circle
the x value is minus one half so let me
see this is the angle that we're trying
to figure out
this is theta
that we need to determine so how can we
do that so this is minus one-half right
here
let's figure out these different angles
and the way i like to think about it is
i like to figure out this angle right
here and if i know that angle i can just
subtract that from 180 degrees to get
this this light blue angle that's kind
of the solution to our problem
so let me make this triangle a little
bit bigger so that triangle
now let me do it like this that triangle
looks something like this
where this distance right here
is one half
that distance right there is one half
this distance right here is one
uh hopefully you recognize that this is
going to be a 30-60-90 triangle you
could actually solve for this other side
you'll get the square root of three over
two and to solve for that other side you
just need to do the pythagorean theorem
actually let me just do that let me just
call this i don't know let me just call
this a so you'd get a squared plus one
half squared which is one fourth is
equal to one squared which is one
you'd get a squared is equal to 3 4. or
a is equal to the square root of 3 over
2. so
you immediately know this is 30 60 90
triangle and you know that because the
sides of a 36 unity triangle if the
hypotenuse is one or one half and square
root of three over two
and you'll also know that the side
opposite the square root of three over
two side is the sixty degrees
that's sixty this is ninety this is the
right angle and this is 30 right up
there but this is the one we care about
this angle right here we just figured
out is 60 degrees
so what's this what's the bigger angle
that we care about
what is 60 degrees supplementary to
it's supplementary to 180 degrees
so the arc cosine or the inverse cosine
let me write that down the arc
cosine
of minus one-half
is equal to
100 and
120 degrees
all right 180 there no it's 180 minus
the 60. this whole thing is 180. so this
is right here is
120 degrees right 120 plus 60 is 180.
or if we wanted to write that in radians
you just write 120 degrees times pi
radian
per
degrees degrees cancel out 12
over 18 is two thirds so it equals two
pi
over three
radians
so this right here is equal to two pi
pi
over 3
radians
now just like we saw in the arc sine and
the arc tangent videos you you probably
say hey okay if i have 2 pi over 3
radians that gives me a cosine of minus
1 half and i could write that cosine
of 2 pi over 3 is equal to minus one
half this gives you the same information
as this statement up here but i could
just keep going around the unit circle
for example i could i will this point
over here cosine of this angle if i were
to add if i were to go this far would
also be minus one half and then i could
go two pi around and get back here so
there's a lot of values that if i take
the cosine of those angles i'll get this
minus one half
so we have to restrict ourselves we have
to restrict the values that the arc
cosine function can take on so we're
essentially restricting its range
we're restricting its range
what we do is we restrict the range to
this upper hemisphere the first and
second quadrants
so if we say
if we make the statement that the arc
cosine
of x is equal to
theta we're going to restrict our range
theta to that top so theta is going to
be
greater than or equal to 0
and less than
or equal to
102 pi
less oh sorry not 2 pi
less than or equal to pi
right or this is also 0 degrees or 180
degrees we're restricting ourselves
to this
part of the hemisphere right there and
so you can't do this this is the only
point where the cosine of the angle is
equal to minus one half we can't take
this angle because it's outside of our
range and what are the valid values for
x
well any angle if i take the cosine of
it it can be between -1 and plus 1. so x
the domain for the
the domain for the arc cosine function
is going to be x has to be
less than or equal to
1 and greater than or equal to
minus 1. and once again let's just check
our work let's see if if the value i got
here that the arc cosine of minus 1 half
really is two pi over three as
calculated by the ti-85
let me turn it on so i need to figure
out the inverse cosine which is the same
thing as the arc cosine
of
of minus one half of minus point five
it gives me that decimal that strange
number let's see if that's the same
thing as two pi over three two
times pi
divided by 3 is equal to that exact same
number so the calculator gave me the
same value i got but this is kind of a
useless what's not a useless number it's
it's a valid that is the answer but it's
it doesn't it's not a nice clean answer
i didn't know that this is 2 pi over 3
radians and so when we did it using the
unit circle we were able to get that
answer so hopefully and actually let me
ask you let me just finish this up with
an interesting question and this applies
to all of them if i were to ask you
you know say i was take the arc
arc cosine
of x
and then i would take the cosine of that
what is this what is this
going to be equal to
well
this statement right here
could be said well let's just say that
the arc
cosine
of x is equal to theta
that means that the cosine of theta is
equal to x
right
so if the arc
cosine of x is equal to theta we can
replace this with theta and then the
cosine of theta well the cosine of theta
is x so this whole thing is going to be
x hopefully i didn't confuse you there
right i'm just saying look arc cosine of
x let's just call that theta
now it by definition this means that the
cosine of theta is equal to x these are
equivalent
statements these are completely
equivalent statements
right here so if we put a theta right
there we take the cosine of theta it has
to be equal to x now let me ask you a
bonus slightly trickier question
what if i were to ask you
and this is true for any x that you put
in here this is true for any x any value
between negative one and one including
those two endpoints this is going to be
true now what if i were to ask you what
the arc arc cosine
of the cosine
of theta is
what is this going to be equal to
my answer is it depends it depends on
the theta so if theta is in the if theta
is in the range if theta is between
if theta
is between
and pi so it's in our valid range
for
for kind of
our range for the product of the arc
cosine then this will be equal to theta
if this is true for theta
but what if we take some some theta out
of that range let's try it out
let's take
so let me do it one with theta in that
range let's take the arc
cosine
of the cosine
of let's just do some one of them that
we know let's take the cosine of let's
take the cosine of 2 pi over 3
cosine of 2 pi over 3 radians that's the
same thing as the arc
cosine
of
minus one half
cosine of 2 pi over 3 is minus one half
we just saw that in the earlier part of
this video and then we we solved this we
said oh this is equal to 2 pi over 3. so
if we're in the range if theta is
between 0 and pi it worked and that's
because the arc cosine function can only
produce values between 0 and pi
but what if i were to ask you
what is the arc
arc cosine
of
the cosine of
i don't know of 3 pi
of 3 pi so if i were to draw the unit
circle here let me draw the unit circle
a real quick one
and that's my axes what's 3 pi
2 pi is if i go around once
and then i go around another pi so i end
up right here so i've gone around one
and a half times the unit circle
so is it three pi what's the x
coordinate here
it's minus one so cosine of three pi is
minus one
right so what's what's arc cosine of
minus one arc
cosine
of minus one
well remember the the range or the set
of values that arc cosine can be can
evaluate to is in this upper hemisphere
it's between this can only be between
pi
and 0. so arc cosine of negative 1 is
just going to be pi so this is going to
be
pi
arc cosine of negative this is this is
negative 1 our cosine of
negative 1 is pi
and that's a reasonable statement
because the difference between 3 pi and
pi is just going around the unit circle
a couple of times and so you get an
equivalent it's kind of your the
equivalent point
on the unit circle so i just thought i
would throw those two at you this one i
mean this is a useful one if well
actually let me write it up here this
one is a useful one the cosine of the
arc cosine of x is always going to be x
i could also do that with
sine the sine
of the arc sine
of x is also going to be x and these are
just useful things to you shouldn't just
memorize them because obviously you
might memorize it the wrong way but just
think a little bit about it and it
you'll never forget it